got a little teaser image from Rockstar
it was kind of this red background with
the rockstar logo kind of we've been
hearing the rumors circulating back
around III right that we might be seeing
a Red Dead Redemption remaster or a new
sequel and now we kind of know based on
the image that we saw today which shows
I think was like six people coming over
the hilltop with that same background
kind of or a group of people it's
clearly read dead 2 or sequel or
whatever leo
Red Dead Redemption 2 red area 2 now we
know Thursday there's gonna be the
trailer dropping we're doing a viewing
party I was talking to rob about it so
we just want to talk today about what we
want from Red Dead Redemption - you
played Red Dead Redemption extensively
I'm stream you be dead redemption - I
never played Red Dead Revolver I did a
lot actually weirdly I was on I played
on the original Xbox like 3rd person
shooter time there's I think there's
actually lot of people that don't too
hardheaded go back to it is it's kind of
it's tough I mean it was really fun
though I mean there were like these boss
fights on these missions they were
different these legendary weapons you
get as you're playing through it and
it's so weird that it became Red Dead
Redemption because there's like eons are
like just so different experiences but
Red Dead Redemption
Justin ones less than you play we played
it recently at all I I played it when it
came out but I mean that's a game that
sticks with you the story in that game
it's still I would say one of my
favorite games of all time you have
those those quiet moments when in other
games when you're just kind of going
across an empty plane like when you're
just going across the world it's boring
but in here it's like it felt like there
was so much life and then you have those
musical hues like they just come up here
like oh I'm going into Mexico or that
part near the end of the game when you
just like you're riding down the hill
and you have the music playing over it
it's like emotionally that still touches
me like I still get chills thinking
about it yeah if there wasn't that bass
the rumbling bass don't-don't-don't like
holy God does you're exactly right
you're just kind of wandering a really
barren desert but it's it's exciting
characters are so so memorable like John
Marston as a character like he nailed
that perfectly that spaghetti western
character who who's kind of on both
sides of the law who's who's an antihero
but someone
also relate with and someone you want to
do well some when you want to win a bad
dude trying to be good and and then he's
forced to be bad again because what the
government comes and yeah it's like
trying to take his land what is the
storyline because I know his family's in
trouble too but I don't know I'm trying
remember what actually I love that game
but there's so much escapes me it such a
big game every now and then I know the
oh no no I'm sorry the government comes
back looking for his ex cohorts from his
gang they're trying to hunt them down
because they've been active again so
then they asked him to go like I thought
the government came down and asked me to
kill a lot of rabbits because I did a
lot of that that's well that's also like
yeah I mean when you look at Grand Theft
Auto 5 obviously this game was read
never and if you do Red Dead Redemption
was 2010 if I'm not mistaken grand theft
auto 5 min 2013 but three years before
that there wasn't as much to do and read
the redemption obviously that's gonna
happen when the grand theft auto 5 comes
out three years after it but I remember
they just nailed that setting like you
said the Jose Gonzales song that plays
when he's come over the hill in Mexico
it's like step in front of a runaway
from it's such a such an awesome moment
like the Sun and like I saw it when the
Sun was going down my friends I was
coming up and like stuff some people saw
it at night I want to go in yeah but it
really nailed that story and that's what
I'm wondering where Red Dead Redemption
2 is gonna go from there because Red
Dead Redemption for as large of a game
as it was a pretty intimate personal
thing it's John Marcin confronting the
people he used to roll with when they
were like robbing trains and banks and
whatnot but psycho revenge tell I don't
know that we should spoil the ending I
mean it's been on a while no please
don't but now that Red Dead Redemption 2
is on the way out like this we'll be
late for the first time for people to
get is I mean it's backwards-compatible
on Xbox one right this we're going to be
playing on Thursday I think but yeah go
play this game because it I'm wondering
how connected two will be to it because
it shows a handful of people like I
don't have people like started looking
at the faces yet on that in the image I
was about to see the face yeah you could
kind of see the whoever is first like
you know the center character it didn't
look like john marston I thought it kind
of did I thought it didn't unless it was
like a prequel or something like we
don't know when it's good there's no
details about aside from like this is
read there item [ __ ] - it's not good
there's there are no confirmed details
but speculation is running that it could
be a prequel so there are seven people
there's one in the middle
hair looks shorter see yeah and it just
gets I mean I've
okay so it's coming out fall 2017 but it
looks like it's got like magnificent
seven vibes or like hateful eight if you
like that I don't know but I'm but they
also said they're gonna have like a new
online experience so that kind of lends
itself you know like maybe it's gonna be
like I'm assuming it's gonna be GTA
online and with in the Wild West and so
I come out months later and then they're
gonna keep introducing new DLC and
despite the fact that I haven't played
it in two years I tell enough people
still play GTA online and like with the
night didn't I do yeah all the time
sometimes if you come in early in the
morning I just see you playing that it's
actually I just saw you playing it today
when you should have been working no I'm
just kidding I'm being a jerk that's a
segue too much time till like GT online
but for what it is I think it's a pretty
fantastic segment to grant the final
five like where it's like just having
seen when it first came out to now it's
pretty wild what like you open up that
game now and it's just like all this
activity going on in the open world like
now to our biker gangs I don't know if
you've even seen and there's new update
it is wild like basically you just step
out your door and it's just chaos not I
mean which you know it's kind of fitting
for Red Dead Redemption right like II if
you can imagine like being in your own
gang and hidden the Old West
yeah that's not this the success that
they found the GTA online like there's
no way they can't bring that idea over
to Red Dead Redemption but part of me
also doesn't want that like that it's a
cool idea and GTA online has done it so
well but the thing that stood out for
Red Dead for me was that single-player
experience something you're not gonna be
able to get in a GT outline as cool as
that is and with GTA online they also
kind of skipped all of the single player
DLC we got promises of more of the story
right and I I don't want them to
sacrifice that element for just the
thing that's going to 100% be successful
and 100% be fun like I still want that
emotional core of a single-player
experience after seeing the teaser image
here's what I thought about GTA 5
introduced you know Franklin Michael and
Trevor you can swap between them on the
fly how ambitious would it be to be able
to swap between seven people in the Wild
West I doubt and that's what I want I
don't know
how possible that is in this day and age
to be able to because that would
seamless in GTA 5 you just you fly up
and then a certain point in the game
once you Omaha call through people meet
them you just fly up go to Franklin over
in this part of LA sorry Los Santos zoom
out go back into Michael do his like
midlife crisis I've got a Trevor psycho
who was in a police chase and there are
different flavors right like trail again
Trevor is doing this police chase stuff
Michaels head go and like these midlife
crisis but also trying not to get into
like too much bad [ __ ] and then you have
like Franklin who himself escaped the
bad stuff to be a better person kind of
like John Marston I guess but that's
ambitious awesome like to be able to
zoom out like go to this person who's
like a robber and then like just like
all just watching all the people come
together because to to sheriff maybe but
I mean obviously the teaser image
implies that they're kind of a gang they
were walking in tour with each other
toward a camera but I'm I'm knowing
Rockstar I'm sure they'll be very
distinct characters I'm kind of looking
forward to seeing how they deal with
that structure because Red Dead
Redemption for all intents purposes
we'll just Grand Theft Auto put into the
Wild West and I would assume they would
try to like take GTA 5's formula and
kind of evolved into something new so
that's what I was hoping because I me
actually make use of this ensemble cast
or even makes that co-op
like that you could play that
single-player experience and each person
takes on a different role and maybe you
can swap out between different ones but
that's you're all playing together but
in a story yeah where do they go from
here like with the world because I mean
the Wild West it was a armadillo Texas
you start off in and then you're kind of
going around Texas over the border to
Mexico what if this is like a Tombstone
Arizona thing or like I don't know what
case do you guys have any ideas for
settings they want to see it in like
what if it's like to see some snow yeah
it's gonna say what if it's like a
hateful eight kind of like the Badlands
of Montana kind of feel well you do like
northern Arizona right like you're even
up there yeah part of the Southwest have
like different clients and just desert
and stuff that'd be awesome yeah I'd
like to see them kind of cuz I mean
aside from that when you go into the
marshes like those swamps and whatnot
and like some of the fields and read
that Redemption
it was all very desert feeling obviously
that makes sense with the Wild West but
I'm kind of looking forward to seeing
where they're gonna set it and like what
cuz like what maybe like they'll take an
actual place in fictionalized account
like mafia 3 date or GTA 5 all the grand
theft auto's did or watchdogs to set in
San Francisco would be cool to see that
gold rush era
mmm-hmm what if what if rocks are a year
after did a better San Francisco 100
years before no I'm not implying
anything I did my free earthquake San
Francisco yeah before the the fires and
whatnot - yeah but like what era right
what like time period yeah yeah cuz
that's like a big deal I mean like again
there's probably I need to look into
like seeing how many people like have
dissected the stuff going on but right
this gang looks cool this one dude's got
a trench coat on bowler hat then one
dude looks leagues out long like
double-barrel shotgun another one's got
a huge gun draped over shoulder the main
who's got a rifle I don't like this like
the fact that they're just the first
image they show off is all seven people
I have to imagine like Justin said maybe
it's I don't know maybe the new online
scares a co-op thing or maybe like I
said you're swapping but I hope to god
you can swap between seven people like
how you would not get bored with that
game people want this is wishful
thinking I don't rock star could do what
they want I'm sure they'll pull it off
but if I was designing this game and I
was like a dictator in the development
studio I'll be like all right or they
would we're gonna be able to swap on the
fly between how many people who wanted
like seven like no really seven get out
you're fired
no they couldn't fire me on the dictator
no but I think you would fire other
people oh and you can't do that and well
you're fired yeah be better no just
kidding I don't know like sure this is
weird that the teaser image itself is
like seven people like they have there
has to be something to that like it's
the first image they're showing off
Thursday at 11 a.m. Eastern Time was
when the trailers dropping 8 a.m. on
time we're gonna be in early in the
morning playing Red Dead Redemption like
7 a.m. I do it put in that power watch
the trailer then we're gonna get
together and talk about it afterward
that trailer is gonna be sick
what do you think the first shot of the
trailer is gonna be a sunrise you know a
sunset I'm saying tumbleweed tell me
wait and then a whistle yeah definitely
wasn't and then I and then a boot in the
dust
so no horse all of a sudden gallops by
from the camera stagecoach
camera underneath the stagecoach like it
rides over dusty the Train Robbery with
seven people that are swapping between
my mama
now imagine if like one of the last
shots does show like that thing like
zooming out and then back into someone
else they wouldn't do that with us I'm
assuming is gonna be a pretty cinematic
trailer and now cuz right now it's fall
2017
who knows when it's gonna actually
release but that's the tentative
placeholder right now I just want more
customization because gee especially
after GTA and how you're able to just
customize every little thing in that
game and I love the costumes and things
you could unlock in Red Dead Redemption
like imagine be able to paint your state
like trick out a stagecoach like crazy
good that get crazy horses and just
paint them however you want yeah like I
want coats of paint I want to paint my
horse I love the idea know someone for
stripe horse there's some some
predictions in the chat Diabolus X or
Diablo sex apologize I'm butchering that
view so the seven people in the picture
could be the people you fight against
maybe a gang you're going after so who
knows bosses super mega loser said maybe
they're all one person but dressed
differently superimposed next to each
other could be a wrecking yeah someone's
saying third guy from the left looks
like John we don't have the images up
right now but it kind of does actually
is wearing that same kind of almost
bowler hat with like a vest on but again
like you get different outfits as John
but yeah I don't know like needless to
say I mean people are kind of like
making fun of everybody for hyping it up
but what if this is tied in to HBO and
this is all gonna sync up with West
world
yeah like robots and whatnot yeah yeah
this is gonna be the playable version of
West's world that's that's how they're
financing it his Rockstar you know they
probably don't have a lot of money they
their games are never very successful
all right do you know okay so you're
telling me that the game is just
repeating the same days mask you'll be
like Majora's Mask and so do I I do
but if Majora's Mask could swap between
seven people so needless to say that
teaser image has got us all excited
try not to hype it up too much but I
don't knowit's rockstar it's always
exciting because they're so secretive
most of the time fall 2017 a tentative
placeholder release date Thursday 11
a.m. Eastern Time the trailers gonna be
up here at GameSpot come back tuned in
probably starting I don't know what time
early in the morning Pacific time like
seven trailers dropping at 8:00 8:00
Pacific so maybe like
we'll be here early we get some coffee
we bring in like bagels or something
we'll be playing Red Dead Redemption on
Xbox one the backwards compatible
version I think Jake and you both have
saves somewhere in the game so we're
gonna we're not gonna start in the
beginning and do all that ranch work and
whatnot but right yeah so I'm looking
forward to the trailer that'll be up and
then we'll right after that convene
again with a bunch of people just never
know if you're gonna be here but you're
gonna wear a couple we hats you'll know
second Street in San Francisco clinking
the longest sidewalk it wouldn't be that
far off yeah alright so Red Dead
Redemption to the trailer is coming out
let us know what you want to see in the
sequel to the 2010 title let us know the
comments below